une production du studio sf
bio sans filtre le bac à ce nom parce
qu'on veut nous inviter whiplash canton
avec moins d'hommes plantes oui on est
un petit concept qui s'en vient on en a
parlé rapidement your happy le zinc ou
je te mets un peu en de spots parce
qu'on a pas reparlé depuis mais on
aimerait faire un genre d'une jarre de
série sans filtre entourant les
élections provinciales qui viennent puis
la façon qu'on aimerait le faire en fait
c'est d'attendre que les le fond je te
prendre par surprise main peut vraiment
puis là on aimerait ça attendre que les
partis politiques principaux déposent
leur glas
leur projet dit qu'ensuite on prime-1 un
sujet par exemple la santé où l'économie
l'environnement qui conçoivent une
personne qualifiée dans le milieu pour
analyser les plateformes de chacun des
partis pour que vous puissiez écouter ce
pays que vous soyez nous aussi
principalement la être plus en mesure de
faire un choix éclairé par rapport à nos
valeurs sûres aux prochaines élections
etc si c'est quelque chose qui vous
intéressent écrivez nous souvent dans
les commentaires un mois ou sur notre
page instagram ou un peu importe tout ce
que vous pouvez nous rejoindre nous
devons nous dire que price une bombe et
puis aussi pour proposer
des sujets en fait pas des sujets mais
genre quel aspect des plateformes
électorales de chacun des partis vous
aimeriez qu'on n'aborde vite demain mcc
sur l'environnement c'est sur ce thème
environnement santé res en cas d
éducation
ça fait qu'ils craignent aussi en a
d'autres économies c'est sûr fait que
river nous donnez nous des idées qu'on
va s'y faire ce genre de rapprocher le
pendant les élections pour être capable
de bien de mieux par un choix éclairé de
nous puis aussi les hoops tout
défoncer des idées d'esquisser les
partis flamands quand on analyse le truc
c'est que des peut déconstruire simple
woippy cessa exact qu'il faut aussi
prendre la peine d'analyser parce que
des fois ça peut vraiment ça peut
paraître plus compliquée que c'est super
on sait pas exactement ça se présente
comme un acte concret des extensions
devraient avoir quelqu'un capable crise
allait sûrement donner son opinion c'est
juste qu'on puisse évaluer les
appariements
très tôt cette semaine dans cette
semaine c'est un grand plaisir de
recevoir de personne qui anime un
nouveau podcast au studio sfr et la
rivière et alanis
qui font un nouveau pas de casque il
faut qu'on s'appelle en fait les filles
nous ont contactés pour qu'on travaille
ensemble qu on l aborde un nouveau
projet des podcasts jonas subversif ok
on travaille là dessus depuis un petit
bout qu'il est maintenant aux antilles
au moment où de ce pack associé au déjà
avoir quatre épisodes de faucon
s'appelle idée qui est en ligne et puis
sont drôles les filles sont allumés qui
sont intéressants c'est vraiment le fun
mon concept en fait cesser ces mesures
qu'ils prennent des nouvelles urgences
ensemble à vis de lui alors c'est
vraiment comme si on monte un lorrain en
ruines de leurs amis puis commence à
être un bon moment avec les autres pays
aussi prennent des appels prennent des
messages des gens du public avec vos
histoires vos questionnements avec pour
réalité pis y réagissent à ce puisqu'on
a fait entre 4 aujourd'hui aussi à la
fin on ne
prix des témoignages du public puis on a
des partis là-dessus
parfois dans l'humour parfois plus
sérieusement on n'est pas les experts on
traite un poil psychologue ou être quoi
que ce soit mais c'est juste un prétexte
en fait pour réfléchir pour discuter
taxi par le fun on a parlé peine à faire
au nom je me suis souvenu ce que j'ai
réalisé que toute l année c'est près
autant que vous connaissez photo da
c'est l'oubli on oublie trop souvent
ouais allégé 17 mois choisi en fait pour
la première activité d'eau des
tentes au point bon et puis je pense
qu'elle était l'avant dernière à choisir
nerveux parce qu'il y avait un gars de
peluches que le nombre de faits puis il
y avait un gars qui allait pas
participer à l'activité saas est ameren
youri puisse allons mener à sa perte la
semaine et que je suis vivant et frère
de yorick treille trop rapide à travers
des yeux ouais mais ouais
d'un drôle de se remémorer ce puits
aussi ont leurs adeptes les sujets comme
ses grandes controverses que les filles
ont traversé bk quelques années j'ai
traversé comment faire affecter quantité
du cvrl serock en a pas en fait comme en
avait parlé j'étais au courant
ça attention ce qu'on écrit trois
des
leurs qui croient pas d'accord mais il
faut rester
pour tomber dans un faux pas d'avenir
une scène pour donner un sens c'est sur
la pente
technique marc jokiel 2
ait coûté broadcast écouter le podcast
est présenté par le studio est ce
dessert c'est quoi le studio studio dans
lequel on est ce qu'on a trois espaces
bien distincts ouais on à l'atelier
atelier le
entre-temps qui l'on trouve en ce moment
on a deux autres locaux si vous écouter
les podcasts vous avez sûrement déjà vu
le studio original qui est le studio
dans lequel on fait ce depuis toujours
et on a aussi le boudoir qui est un
endroit plus intime plus
confortable vraiment pour avoir des
discussions intime seul à seul avec
quelqu'un
puis on a un bel espace si tout pouvait
venir prendre un café jazz et avec vos
invités donc ce qu'ils voulaient faire
un podcast vous voulez faire une
conférence un cours en ligne avec
n'importe quel contenu audiovisuel ou
juste audio ou juste 18 ans estime bain
pour inertie c'est la place pour vous
toutes les informations en fait écrit
vigneault ou un faux at the west point
ses yeux pour voir toutes les années
exact qui ça vient aussi avec tout avec
le matériel complet ça vient avec le
techno la technique le technicien nicole
qui est l'heure pour vous accompagner ça
vient avec tout et en tout temps tout
afflux soudain ans
formé au club
seul home est donc là c'est qu'on vous
envoie pas les fichiers vidéo les
fichiers audio tout sépare yb le fou
quand vous sortez votre de ses démons
pour mettre ça en ordre pour faire des
montages date pour 5 et le son l'image
qui laissa sa boxe ça ça dit synchronise
puisse la vie c'est là comme s'était pas
au début initialement blanche l on
possède pas de casse toi on va pas
au début du sans-fil podcast d'hommes
faisait si on arrache avec deux caméras
quatre micros des fois trois micros 3 4
micros ne donne pas c'est qu'en même
temps par podcast à faire le montage à
10 ans 3,83 4 eur 3,4 avec en plus
d'enregistrer podcast de cet élément clé
qui n'aime pas ces trois quatre heures a
brillé à éditer le podcast puis ce qui
lui est bon en plus pour son étude
n'avait aucune crise dès que vous allez
pas surprendre 10h papa de quatre ici
comme dame dit c'est le fichier vient
les montages sont les caméras les
plaques à métro sont réglés le son est
synchronisé et mixé déjà façonne bien sa
salle où que vous avez les bons plans
très bonne personne au bon moment tout
se fait en
simultané en live c'est vraiment
fait que ce diocèse point ses impôts à
studio sf points 6
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça lui allait au loup vous est pas
inconnu à ce studio non non
on est aussi fait sienne la serious man
fait leurs
deux fois on his her way plus que nous
et non mais c'est pas que vous êtes plus
sérieux que nous c'est que vous avez là
est tellement plus intelligents que nous
mais moi ce que je
fais non non non non ça semble non on
connaît bien on fait déjà une vie
parfaite
aucune faillite des caisses
j'en avais déjà parlé comme le moment
pas de cas sur ce que je fais ce genre
c'est vraiment intéressant sur le genre
en alsace j'essaie de réfléchir à qu'est
ce que je peux dire non parce que c'est
quand même y aurait plus rien n'était
fait que chaque fois que chaque franc
sans fil que je fais jamais ça c'est
vraiment intéressant dans ma tête je
voulais fois que juste comme j'écoute
l'invité par madrid comme le meilleur au
non sens en voyeur plus je pense à genre
je m'attends tout tu fais quand une
affaire pis le jeu le chant que la
personne va finir ce cas là dit plus
parce que ça veut dire c'est que quand
même pas très s'il pouvait rester bas
jamais dira le fait un peu défaut
méthode mais avec ce témoin ouais ça
qu'on ai deux je pense pour cela c'est
la doublette et parce que quand même
temps être seul tu peux juste pas de
permanents faire seul et il faut tout le
temps que soit j'en remets ton si moi je
fais sur leur chic doumbo peut-être
d'avoir de quoi dire mais si les deux on
le fait en même temps ça donne le moment
oui c'est vraiment été
chaque fois maintenant je coche alors
leurs mots sont tellement réfléchi this
is pause pillon qu'ils pensent vraiment
qu'est ce qu'ils disent en tout cas de
prendre le temps de penser ça te donne
le temps de réfléchir
mais c'est mon cerveau il pense même pas
à penser je me souviens béton on a plus
l'impression qu' il ya des longues
pauses cancon et en vrai puis le monde
qui écoute tu mets ton des fois je
répondais à faire qu'on a fait ou des
votants 58 des fois il ya des pauses que
pendant que telle dans le podcast un
moment que germaine et le mans et bombay
inside et jean luc et pendant trois
secondes sauf que finalement tous les
coupes c'est jusqu'à temps qu'il
réfléchit quiz mais jusqu'en juillet
autrefois les je pense c'est une
question qu'on avait reçu la visite
chaque homme il faut qu'ils parlent
s'arrête finalement je les écoute après
c'était possible dirigeants hexagonaux
les vedute était peu long mais oui c'est
vrai puis à 4 sata difficile de faire un
podcast mettons-nous ans coupable à
quatre sites quand on s'est rendu compte
que c'est plus au 4e vraiment que deux
avec une personne moins à 4 des fois
justement ça devient ça peut devenir
un crack folie locale paulo titi bramont
une place et puis c'est quand même
plutôt fin
mai la salle à fort sur lequel on a
contrôlé c'est comme nous comment nous
on fait le tri fait qu'on me cite
maintenant qu'on a un invité seul qui
parle pas beaucoup le nous on va parler
plus le gars qu'on est à cartons comme
le système baklouti comme d'un paquet
qu'on a fait un cadre d'un book cédric
les guides sont tellement il parle
tellement ils sont tellement intenses
gens dont on est comme un peu plus en
bas on va
la mairie meetic indique en tête avec du
monde qui t'aiment genre vraiment ça
serait sa pile avec est tellement
différent que c'était drôle
c'était vraiment très différent fait de
ce qu'on fait d'habitude mais pour
bosser c'est vraiment cool parce que ça
nous a permis de voir un autre côté vous
aussi dit qu on voyait pas qu'on voit
moins bien en ce sens que comme nous on
est l'image des ph et d'hommes qui parle
si j'aurais même temps déjà
mais je confirme bien non
depuis que j'ai commencé le podcast
c'est là
ils sachent qu'ici j'aurais qui savait
[Rires]
mais oui je comprends
mais wade mais je parle pas de la casse
touche tellement avec 110 kg et adam en
jeu j'écoutais des peaux de castor
américain que j'aime bien qui faisait un
genre de genre de rétrospective après
500 épisodes puis il disait le top cinq
enfants qui ont appris mettons pizza
toujours prioriser les amis au nom de
l'invité maintenant acquise à défendre
ainsi de recevoir des comédiens vraiment
connu le podcast des genres codec
chacune torsion un ami qui comme moins
connus ou un ami qui comme
le podcast et olten 5 parce que l'ami
comme sword est
vrai que c'est plus connectés
oui c'est istomin un podcast est
tellement oui ça peut tomber facilement
corps paul mais à la base ça reste des
discussions humaines cependant apprécié
qu'à quai mais prenez ça mange ça le met
naturellement officines et le flou la
plus basse et là ça ça nourrit plus au
sud se nourrit la conversation sur un
feu d oui futur mais à davos est collé
il me fait capoter
tout terrain oui je peux kamal des
crises
incroyable pour ace vraiment et c'est un
personnage mais tout le temps comme ça
c'est son personnage c'est vraiment lui
semble
exagéré son personnage peut y arriver
elle même aussi très
mal fun
gro big
fait rire la mangue ses seuls comme cet
incident est vraiment ses succès
sur d'ouvriers un drôle
et mont wright jacques sur dwayne
roloson même pas exprès un peu c'est
ouais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est bon vous avez une bête la
mecque ce cas vous avez rencontré un bon
ya
pas de hasard comme a
commencé à connecter c'est fou on s'est
raconté un fond et on est une amie
commune que ben non c'est non à une amie
c'est un contrat que j'avais c'est qu'on
a une boutique et hervé pour magasiner
je suis incollable a vécu et le gras
photographe 17-12 de la boutique ou de
la colonne des la petite oie et c'est
vrai je prenais des photos des genres et
dans la boutique match était comme un
mois sans contrat que j'avais cette
journée le thé arriver oui c'est la
photo avec mais vivait chez au bbv chier
immigrés c'est vrai dans ces petits
chiens sont rentrés et a aujourd'hui
j'ai reconnu le gie valable mais ont
suivi ça faisait un bout de temps sur
les réseaux p2p mais quand j'ai vu ça
ensuite à l'eau comme si on se
connaissait depuis vraiment longtemps
pour la connecter tout de suite tu vois
je céderai que j'oublie que je te
connais 7 d'avancé réseau mais oui puis
c'est ce que ça te rapproches proche des
gens tu as l'impression de caractère
qu'on ne peut pas tout à 5 2 j'aime tout
autant que ça mélangé parce que tu peux
avoir une perception d'une personne qui
est totalement impossible d'avoir une
image la personne du cas des gages
résultats membres et iv ilbo
y sommes plus tu vas été positive dans
le sens qu'il rencontre la personne
puisse études genre mon ami ou gepi
cheveux trop est ton ami placé comme
mieux
mais les premières rencontres 10 ans
dans un sens qui mettons je sors je
pense à 1 go cube ont suivi les deux
puis un but fait de la musique et la
musique ça y est on est une équipe on
trinque en place et comme et oui ça lui
même est laid c'est comme ci dessus j'en
ai mangé deux moustiques commencent qu'à
l'est déjà
c'est tout à la même affaire et on
serait dans ce cas les bottes d'un ouais
c'est vrai c'est ce que tu veux pas
faire non plus comme si tu étais un
parfait inconnu au salut moi c'est
dominique plainte
non plus comme si tu as une cave à
personne c'est d'en bas et et qui n'ont
pas avec le
groupe acquéreur on s'est connus de même
puis après comment qu'on a quand un
sport pourquoi
pas si j'avais
un
petit gourou j'allais faire des
contrôles à bord venait la propriété la
boutique celle de ses deux mines au
tamis des deux wild parce que c'est eloi
mon garçon qui est faite que c'est
arrivé plus vite te rappelle comment
vous avez connectivité loi puis toi ça
évite de vous promener main dans la main
la première fois oui on fait ça me joue
lgt spécial son bébé
voyez comme un succès en argentine
il regarde capital humain est
tombé bay et tencent bois allumés
points puis on a parlé d'autres avalent
podcast pour venu battre conditions
croquettes de poulet avec semaine inside
et le piment c'est vraiment drôle mais
temps d'écouler gift est alarmiste et la
mort des moines mon enfant est vraiment
intelligent plus là personnage c'est
quoi ton nom à son enfant
mais voyez quelque chose les sketches
dans le in fameux sketch dans la moelle
des regards regarde la photo mon bébé
comme acquis book
[Rires]
il nous a montré qu'on énonce la g ces
lieux demande qui qu'un qui deviennent
mères devienne ma fille qui qualifie ses
collègues si c'est vraiment qu'il ait
fait une bêtise mais vous ne m'avez pas
du tout la
seule jamais
[Rires]
[Musique]
ouais mais non oui c'est vrai qu'on est
comme si on perd on est tout le temps on
veut pas oublier qu'on est dans des
femmes dit on du bye bye à toutes les
études le la partie réseaux sociaux me
laisser comme
ça finit puissance embarque la dalle
mais cette partie le trou qui s'est en
tout cas mettant une étiquette ondrais
détruit des biens de marc plus qu'un
cinquième des comics ou de femmes
instagram peu comme
si c'est pas obligé
mais c'est vrai que c'est comme mais
vous le savez vous êtes là on est vous
êtes la première génération a comme
avoir des enfants quand ils les les
réseaux sociaux sont une puissance là où
est ce qu'il ya une génération mettons
de personnes
publiques mouton le des créateurs de
contenu ou à lèvres comment qu'on veut
appeler sud mais fait que s'il ya comme
pas deux pas de marche à suivre personne
qui l'a fait vraiment il est pas de bon
ni de mauvais exact est mise en avant
avec tout et qu'on veut pas faire ce
genre a fait le tour du monde c'est
comme
jugement m'ont enfin devant qui m'ont
pas du tout la fin et devant qui le che
kampot sais c'est quoi la
whey jusqu'où ça vaut ce l'exacte copie
correcte c'est quoi qui les patins pour
certaines personnes camarades c'est
comme je monte mon enfance c'est son
choix pour moi je m'en fous pierre nuque
c'est comme
si j'allais dire parce qu'ils émeutes
ont comme ces mêmes jeux montrés loi
pourquoi je montrais loi que je mens
même pas vos propres enfants le monde me
demande souvent oui ces temps là est
vraiment ri ouais enfin d'un autre
people tient mais je pensais juste à la
limite à toi
on sait les raisons pourquoi qui est à
limete plus et moins haut que moi ou si
chaque humain caychac même humanité
sarrus femmes qu'elles viennent montrer
loi puis je te comprends l'été c'est la
plus belle personne de vie dans ta vie
août à moi mais où ira le plus beau que
dans le monde pour moi mais on dirait
qu'ils aient respecte aussi parce que
c'est ma job c'est du travail plus ces
réseaux sociaux moins que tu as été
mauvaise expérience un petit peu de
commentaires aussi moi je lis plus là
contre non mais la controverse de trucs
tu veux pas embarquer là dedans tu sais
dans mon pc comme seule chose me tonti
ce qui est à moi le piquer les
jaillissements peuvent contrôler deux
subi on met une tête sur 100 parlais
tantôt les je prends une super belle
photo du photographe puis elle sa peau
ça marche pas mais le jeu mais une photo
avec mon enfant de dos ça marche ouais
mais ce feeling le qui était comme ça
marche avec mon enfance est tellement
malsain ouais ouais il a apprécié comme
il aurait pu limite si je commence à
tomber là dedans des jeunes je les fais
quitter je me restreins quand même
beaucoup parce que j'embrasse toutes les
photos nues ou avec mes hobbies tout
mais moi je trouve ça juste tellement
malsain les feelings dire à l'heure
beaucoup de laïcs cette photo l'homme on
a failli même pas conscient chez mais il
a fait des fois ce justement l'espèce de
quantic ans a checké mettons des stats
ce python engagements de ces choses mais
je le fais plus ça fait vraiment
longtemps que j'ai complètement arrêté
deux turcs et hop ça me rendait c'est le
genre physiquement mais je comprends
puis
mais quand tu tombes dans ce pays on le
voit plus évidemment je n'aimerais
vraiment pas non parce que c'est facile
mais mais tu vois du monde clairement
c'est réfléchi d'avoir des photos avec
leurs enfants parce que parce que c'est
les photos qui marche c'est l'engagement
mais piece
505 d'utiliser un autre être vivant pour
booster ta propre comme étant
tombé dedans parce que tu dis
une photo de m puis l'a pas beaucoup
d'engagement que le prochain qu'à
l'habitude peut charger plus c'est quand
même facile de tomber dans cet incident
a franchi
fou ça c'est fou vraiment quittée au
mais apporte tout seul le truc marseille
sait que c'est dangereux ou si j'avais
vu justement dit ac oui c'était triste
le gentil comme tout les statisques
compter sur tictoc directement tu vois
le nombre de gens qui ont enregistré les
lecteurs qui l'ont envoyé tout ce qui
est technique avec des petites filles
dans ces genres en petite robe ou
enseignement plus qu il était genre dix
fois plus regardée que les enfants
s'entraînent qui je peux je peux pas
croire un taxi le far west le naf arrive
à 24,4 les gendarmes mais on avait mis
juste nos extraits de sans-fil tic tac
ont déposé nos extraits même chose les
mêmes extraction les déposer plainte
mais notre note gaie qui faisait sur un
fond il a écrit à fait légale allez voir
les commentaires
les commentaires sur twitter que c'était
d'un ridicule
insein c'était genre contexte est juste
des monsieurs de genre 40 ans
complètement des cris d'enfants vraiment
oui foule jeunes au genre des adoptants
six écoles déjà
écrire des de l'estimable savait pas de
sens je comprends pas pourquoi c'est que
les mentalités évoluent partout mais sur
techtoc
[Rires]
fou peut s'aimer chez
j'ai lu un roman sur ce sujet-là la
faune se remettant
[Rires]
capitale est super il partit en avant
mais ça s'appelle les enfants sont rois
c'est sur une fille qui comme
qui elle a toujours des téléréalités
laisser les fameuses pas m'emmener
justement ce que ce qui marche pour elle
c'est de faire une chaîne youtube avec
ses enfants c'est sans fin qui font des
débats les cadeaux qui font l'équipe
côté ils vont bon train dans mon style
et ça marche foules sont la fable
élément déclencheur
prix cinéma paribas fois king bon bon
bon moment puis mais ça parle de tout et
tu aimes le plus justement c est ce que
c'est je pense qu'elle là on parlait de
là la limite la ligne j'arrête ou je
pense que montrer son enfant je souhaite
aussi toute la ville se tourne sauf que
c'est ce qu'a cas c'est rendu que te
fait travailler ton
[Rires]
ballon
mais
je pars n'est pas par les temps qui sait
je pense d à quel point c'était faire au
nom m'a dit moi je le sais parce que
tout le monde ne parlait et mettons dans
nos intimités mjahl mais d'en parler
publiquement tu le peux chanter les gens
savent même pas quel point ça peut faire
mal à kalinka trouvé c'est comme cela
qu'est ce que les gens disaient même
péché mais pas comme un an non moi
c'était avec sos ou pour le pire mais
tant pis y est
mais j'avais fait un tweed jockey je me
demandais si je lai des enfants puis les
relations ni planétaire c'est vrai que
tu l'aimés à côté études et puis j'avoue
le même moi j'ai regardé ce que j'avais
fait ouais vraiment moyen comme posthume
et les usa lui grégory mais ça passe et
ça passe et mettons de jeu mais je me
rappelle exactement le ca passé comme
d'un manque de jugement un tel choix de
colas pour je sais pas pourquoi mais
pour une raison sur 90 avis les excès
sûrement vraiment que la payant que le
il pense pas que tu prends ton char de
toute façon non mais je pense pas trop à
ça mais ça passait dessus un genre foca
disparaissent la
foulée
je pense qu'à ce moment là j'ai checké
encore plus les foules important j'avais
perdu comme vingt trente mille abonnés
c'était genre la fin de ma ville je
pleurais dans mon lit soit mon intimité
comme au québec a right stuff à autre
chose au pays si moi je visais pas grave
si je suis pris n'est pas grave mais dit
mais c'est aussi deux au delà des seuls
st jean les gens souhaitaient la manche
personnes c'était comme ça allait encore
plus loin que j'eusse liste à peine six
mois et se sait quel genre grec tu
recules je sais que le monde autant
comme sur technique c'est facile de le
dire mais mais quand ça t'arrive
sais je sais je sais je sais je sais à
ce que tu penses tu pensé à eux mais oui
mais oui vraiment c'est vraiment un gros
nuage qui restent longtemps mais si mais
si clément si on m'a parlé justement
hier le lieu le mieux du monde qui ont
absolument rien à faire ses matons -
georges voici maintenant je capable de
me dire pas le meilleur mot dans une
capable de trouver sur un peu tâté
cohérente anti-copie même passé ce
commentaire le puits mais ne peut pas de
m'en parler le direx auxerrois
commencé à laisser trouver chez vous le
ton en vis et comment t il comme le
souhaitait la misère à quelqu en soit et
maman à quelqu'un souhaitait genre là
personnes disparaissent à cause d'une
erreur de jugement est restée le camp
puis les gens y maletas famille assez le
moment recevait des taux réduits lavaur
tellement malade on entoure avec
moi comme tu veux mais pareil
on m'a demandé si
j'étais resté un peu comme tout intérêt
à laisser sa main ouais vraiment mais
j'ai vraiment deux mondes qui se passe
la majorité du monde mais le monde
pour s'amuser me retire comme du plaisir
à voir quelqu'un qui te semble avoir du
succès qui c'est qui ouais
piqué tomber un tipi quitter ils vont
surtout ici ma tante est l'expression né
pour un petit pain au québec si ça vient
pas de nulle part l'expression
est venu pour un petit point ce genre
donc on n'aspire pas vraiment
la réussite succès au grand succès puis
au québec on a de la misère à voir
quelqu'un a réusi à moi je me rappelle
un pis ça va toujours marqué cette
histoire là parce que un gars du
saguenay pierre lavoie je pense que ça
c'est qui le grand défi pierre lavoie
c'est un lieu que eu énormément de
succès avec une fondation qui est pour
amasser des fonds pour la recherche
contre la maladie depuis
un an et jeta québec le pierre il ya
comme dévoilé que dans sa fondation une
fondation vraiment se défend comme une
version challenge je sais même pas c'est
quoi le bâton qui sont versées sans mes
pièces de sa 125 me plains pas puis là
il y avait un chroniqueur d'une radio à
québec puis en a beaucoup des
chroniqueurs de marbre à québec qui
commençait alba chez pour se verser un
salaire de au dessus d'un salaire moyen
mais tant pis sa fondation changer des
vies
sauvées millions même donné
littéralement des dizaines de millions
de dollars à la recherche et à toutes
puis un esti chroniqueur à radio qui
chialent pour le moyen de dire qui lui
verse trop l'argent c'est quand même je
veux pas juste être content que
quelqu'un
cette espèce de vision un peu perverse
pourvoyeur de d'aimer ce work semble
réussir comme des
chutes etc quand ça arrive ils vont
sauter dans le train pour relier à
checker puis à participer à cet
événement oui et puis maintenant ça
comme plus d'emplois parce que ça a
toujours fait partie l'humanité les
jeunes - le truc hyper bon le monde
frimer avec les réseaux sociaux et les
écrans les gens oseraient pense qu'ils
sont comme pour un nu nécessairement il
veut se cacher de rang des confections
plus facilement mais des messages de
mort de menace de tout seul dans ce cas
vont rester plus difficile
un jour il manque maintenant me
promenais lancé des oeufs ou des tartes
dans le monde sait sauf que je mange
l'été était miné mâche pas ses mots qui
se déplacent pour mettre une passe de
jean chrétien we
were ses propres incohérences le monde
qui était écrit lyon tout des chars
électriques se montrent
jamais personne qui a accepté de
l'argent d'une compagnie qui pourrait
correspondre à une personne là dedans
non c'est juste que la caricature et en
tue tout humaine on met tout les sens
dans notre charge c'est pour reprendre
mettons cet exemple la différence entre
un maître pour en faire la promotion
mais tout le monde mais de l'essence
dans son champ tout le monde contribue à
sur le tir oui fait que genre et sous le
résistant encore que tu as ou non la
publication le monde va aller chez les
sous entendus et le mans qui critiquent
ces seule comme d'habitude autant tesla
si la somme est aimé ton mac do et
accessoires a tissé un truc tu as cause
qui a été fait déploré
après ça tout le monde tout le monde
maintenant je sais il dit compagnie
parfaitement et il y en a peut-être mais
je sais c'est fou comme angélique de
plaissan peut penser enfin y avait une
personnalité très connue le genre très
très connus qu'aimer kroes qui comme nat
toutes les séries
c'était
le même commentaire j'ai trouvé ça
carrément pas qu'il est là parce que lui
ça a été un des premiers à sauter à
sauter sur ta contreverse puis après
c'est dans une pub de mecs d'eau puis on
sait très bien que mcdo c'est un plus
grand pollueur que solitude genre c'est
comme frapper à la porte des choses
longueuil soit subhash quelqu'un que je
ne peux pourrait si on met tout était
tout sourire marathon doublette big mac
beken chez mcdo
l'étendre à ta propre et cohérent à mal
ses jeux comme j'ai même pas de mots
comment que cette façon loft à dix après
jetée puis je pense à bien
les rushs période je m'excuse mais je
pense à bien des bleus mon mac règne de
foi des podcasts à prêter j'ai dit mais
ça pour ça on avait parlé c'est sa
famille n'avait pas eu dès que tu dis
pitt et les podcasts en reste tellement
longtemps sur une story c'est ce fait
que l'esthétique est chaud et nombreux
styles ça m'a vraiment traumatisé mais
t'as pas aller loin si comme étant un
exemple de m'installer avec meoli tulle
avec de la musique demain oui je sais ça
a été loin aussi les appels à des pays
comme
si chaque image est ce qu'ils montrent
non j'attends plus pauvres est belle et
surtout en ce moment achetant un simple
fait les jambes et on tue pour répondre
de quoi est ce parce qu'elle est
enceinte c'est comme incontrôlable je
virais l'atabal anvers et ce quelque
chose sur mon enfance il dit quelque
chose dont moi même ont enfin
oui ça se contrôle paul six possessions
fait qui est oui
le laisser comme il ya ce que le format
blonde ajar les réseaux sociaux vos
réseaux sociaux plus
vrai possible qu'il ya dedans privé mais
tu es une fille qui dit qui y est dit
que l âme et on a travaillé dans
différents sites subie
à fait juste des story avec une de ses
amies qui aide des enfants
pied du mont qui appelait dpj pour cet
enfant là juste à cause qui est à
proximité de sept personnes qui
travaillent dans ces cas c'est la folie
mais tant que tu arrives il est rugueux
la dpj et on agit comme un ami qui a mis
avec un directeur du chipeau kwal qui
comme boss dans des piges et pillent
avait demandé et alanis fin à ce qui se
passe est dispo seriez vous savez le
nombre d'appels tonneaux à cause du
monde ces réseaux sociaux plus les
personnalités connues mais ton parce
qu'elles montrent juste un maillon d
aider le voir faire de faire tomber les
autres qui voter ouais c'est fous
pareils vraiment pis les gens sont avec
mon ampli ont peu d'enfants non mais si
ce type d'imagés comme ya peu bizarre
même pas trop c'est bien non systar à
partir une fille qui m'avait écrit un
enfant elle savait par rapport au chalet
la star qui perd avec jean 16 ans berlin
28 ce sujet oui oui je sais ça fait
chier quand même des masques des stocks
tout en sauvegardant peu total personnes
qui derrière ses conclu mais quand on
regarde des photos qui
ça peu sa place parce que c'est un peu
ma jambe
exact la porte des messages qu'on le
médecin tu clique dessus petit jard un
adolescent qui cherchent vraiment
beaucoup pikit est un genre moi je me
suis fait ça fait vraiment longtemps
nous pas fait insulter maintenant droit
depuis lille va passer pierre tullaye
alex tanguay qui m'écrit jean romanet
cité l'es20 jouer et me dit à 0,2 et
0,6 à faire dans un autre choix glace et
s'habiller comme toi on met tongs fait
que le fcc jungle c'est leur hymne au
jardin oui une photo de moi qui comme
ces domaines à 15 heures de cours je
m'alimente
ce genre de toute évidence un gode 13
ans qui se laisse
[Rires]
vous ferez normal un adolescent ben
normal j'ai qu'un pétard
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas grandi avec
c'est la mémoire pouvoir littéralement
si je veux écrire à guillaume de pages
peut y écrire au men ta barbe et à fos
win
[Rires]
au canada c'est quoi grandes stn ou
parce que moi c'est calme
et l'activité dé nous deux mais même au
québec mais littéralement au circus ou
instagram dont le potentiel ne pas
écrire à n'importe qui n'importe quelle
personne
je sais même pas comment je réagis moi
même parce que vraiment quand j'étais
adolescent moi aussi je faisais pas
l'apport des choses puis avait du monde
que je détestais sans aucune raison la
bcc jusqu'à écrire sitariste belgique un
terme à 17 soit ils oublient ou l'autre
l'oubli ou rêveurs mais le sari est le
pouvoir et en 2013 et c'est qu'il fait
sur facebook le fact et comme sur
lafarge s'arrêtera simple ouais ouais ça
prend moins de gosse écrit claude
quelqu'un qui dit en pleine face c'est
tellement facile ah oui oui ça pour ça
comment kevin
conway gilles
savary non autant on disait tu
l'apprends génération enfin deux gamins
crossroad on dirait puis je pense que je
pense que tranquillement c'est comme si
tu allais vraiment loin je pense qu'il
prend qu'il ment ça revient un peu
[Musique]
agaçant
mais c'est comme tout ce qui est témoin
des fois j'ai l'impression que j'ai
toutes nos habitudes reviens tu es un
moment donné c'est quoi qui était faux
la mode j'aime par exemple
mais a insisté la mode elle suppose que
c'est parce qu'on vieillit aussi le
montrait que lui ce qui est plus balisée
ces gens allaient fois du père noël un
autre ex tout en une boucle qui revient
fait qu'est-ce que ça vous revenez qu'à
un moment donné on va déjeuner officiel
ou fait dans 300 da je sais pas mais
c'est un autre choix vu nos enfants par
téléphone mais oui mais oui juste qu'on
met dedans
enfin non ce sera pour des crèmes et
autres cet ancien joueur comme
collectivement on va faire genre et on
essayait ce
convoi juste si merci quand vous êtes
comme je
peux comprendre qu'il ait été croqué on
ça va se faire seul piqué on voit
revenir à la
bouille son journal
avec les méthodes lui ce moment là c'est
comme ça mais il
ya des luttes et maintenant il apparaît
avec google pour marc desjardins
lunettes que j'ai filmé ce que tu vois
mais aussi chercher des enfants
maintenant avec un quart de civils le
site ynet danse avec tes yeux magie mmi
mais c'est comme ça on dirait qu'on
dirait que ces genres
on peut imaginer ou et ça peut aller
mais ça me tente vraiment pas que ça et
le nom
n'est pas exactement ce à quoi dans ma
vie où est ce qu'il va faire acquis et
non le chemin vous vu dans une cabane en
bois oui je suis complètement et
pourrait ces substrats normal c'est
tellement intense tout ce monde le sait
fou c'est soit que manet un corps humain
et pète aux frites la sspa marque fait
justement qui se retire de toutes
tailles d'or il ya comme une pièce wade
lui-même et son seul dans une pièce me
piégeant d'être
loyal
mais si je vois comment je suis moi y
est
forte comme étant sans filtre les ça
fait un bout alors que 84 à 81 c'était
en août était un nouveau commence fait 4
1 fin mai
des journées 18 touches pas ses premiers
pas de sel
nicole va dans voir c'est quoi la date
du premier sans filtre
match là
les armes mais y'avait james qui était
qui était plus longtemps je sais pas si
on a joué on va voir si on est assez
whaou ont eu la pression la fin je
ressens de la pression à west ham a de
la pression en même temps
oui
ça fait quatre c4 à qui on
s'est foutu - ouais ouais on a changé le
prince et pour le savez évoluer
soit casque éjecté avec markit cité dans
une de vos cuisines pourra bien si ce
genre d'épisode devant chez nous au
début le cht fouet
aujourd'hui seuls mais oui mais non
c'était comme moi souci c'est une chose
qui me passionne les gens qui savent
prendre mais tant qu est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui est pas encore un mode
mais qui veut donner foi du peuple a
piqué genre ce avant gardiste
mais honnêtement pour planter des fleurs
mais genre depuis qu'on fait pas de
casque dans le temps il y avait jean rey
avait pas de gascogne ou québec en avait
trop
regarder 45 points
s'il y avait quoi qu'il faisait vraiment
longtemps et qui est pour beaucoup c'est
vraiment plus longtemps t il était déjà
très connu dans le milieu de l'humour
les podcasts parce que justement les
phrases pleines d'humour est ce qu'on
faisait pas de casse mais ces podcasts
plus de conversations avec des experts
aussi des témoins axée sur le com faire
des jo que j'ai tranché il n'avait pas
tant pis notons en fait on était plus
influencé par des trucks aisé aux states
is est il de la vague avec des jeux
comme commencer ailleurs
c'est juste une des fans tirées pour
passer plus que ceux de jean sait pas si
stratégiques déjà
juste comme ça donne on écoute ce on va
on fait surprenant gold sépia a donné
aussi que c'est ça qui m'a donné que je
sortais d'eau des faits qu'il avait la
chance d'avoir ce genre de visibilité le
10 puis
ça fait 4 1 c'était l'été elle était en
sortant
oui c'est ça va tourner ça fait presque
cinq heures c'est donc ce qu'ils
faisaient
on dirait que je fais là on était proche
de on est en effet allé en voyage
la natation parce que j'avais pas
compris voient les règles des règles
assez une vingtaine d'années contient 21
21 ou fait que
plus je réussisse à la nouvelle zélande
tablette aurait prêté ligne pour la
première fois parce que j'en avais
l'immunité si on avait été son état
allait
[Rires]
il ya des gens j'ai fait comme une jarre
de rétrospective de caisse qui avait
écrit quoi le tube j'aurais programme
pas dû faire ça mais il y avait une
nageuse qui nagent avec moi au rouge et
or il ya comme commenté sur vers le
groupe n'a effectué que la fédération de
natation du québec
bilan après avoir perdu une épreuve de
natation
là
[Rires]
je me rappelais plus de
ces feux qui car les bateaux c'était
tellement beau bateau de pirates dans
l'eau plus bleu que j'ai jamais je
suis petit je pensais la même toile à
nice qui avait dire ph alors jean rolin
pique tout est revenue tout est comme
elle est on va
se parler
j'arrive déjà
s'assurer pdif déjà même poste par les
gens non mais c'est plus pour ça ça a
comme par rapport que je fasse
d'activité l'hôtel qui prévalent à la
salle à l'épreuve par des bouées fois le
film qui j'en avais bruit en plus
notamment design et sur mesure pour que
tu puisses show off tesquet week end
pidgornyy
et l'hôpital perdican jarlet la personne
- noyau 15 membres n'ont pas toutes la
bouille
mécanique avait pas de la luire ton
aissati la veille ou non à mon du filet
j'allais vite le ballon file à when we
feed
roger derue
ayem ça c'est drôle de penser que vous
étiez ou dans mes valises que l'est et
c'est vous étiez où ils sont et je
connais pas les gentils moi je peux
rester dans ce milieu là effectué par
rencontrer les cg peut-être rencontré
renaud après nos des bagadoù
pas car il ya un mois et demi comme
étant illégal j'ai pas vraiment
rencontrer les gars d autres d autres
années mais entre que moi je suis
vraiment encore proche de degen notre
année c'est vrai que la tendance à
frapper fort
boudiba l'iss quand même rester marie
curie avec sa marque et québec jarrier
il y en a
d'accord c'est vrai c'est
que je suis post traumatique
genre l'autre jour on voulait juste
montrer inquiet par joanie de sexuel
allaient jamais vue n'avait pas écouté
et avec exemple on voulait montrer
certains moments je puis le jeu s'entend
d'un musée à revoir le monde qui étaient
là c'est quand même je peux pas regarder
non
c'était juste un oui
pour être resté une semaine puis des
fois autant que des fois j'ai
l'impression que j'ai jamais fait ça de
ma vie tmx était chaude puis d'autres
fois je suis comme
ça je pourrai pas enchaîner ce pas que
j'allais rester plus longtemps parce
qu'ils sont restés longtemps c'était
vraiment seul
jusqu'à vraiment fin c'était il n'ya
plus rien qui se passe derrière lui
derrière les visages
investisseurs de foule ils sont tous de
notre nataliste comme à premier acte du
come-back les contrées qui avait rien
d'organisé ouais c'est ce lot comme
londres et que sa retraite il les nuits
à la place on ose ouvrir alors je pars
l'apesi maintenant puis a dit qu' ils y
ont fait il est comme des trois semaines
en attente de la finale dotée en grèce
le sont à la white qui sont restés le
puits a déjà songé à louer un jet puis
on fait le tour d'hawaï sont promenés
tinto ces gens on a loué une villa notre
nounou avait un nul ce soir dan huss il
rester couchés sur on n'a pas le droit
de sortir la ville avec des trois
semaines
enfin on attend que ça finisse le test
est pas mal non plus
avec une enceinte puis il faut le
respect pour seul mr ancienne religieuse
qui était plus religieuse qui
redécouvraient toutes les plaisait de la
ville fait que jean raby que tout le
temps
non je peux pas sauter puis moi dès
qu'un esprit fallait jamais couché ouais
il avait un nouveau tube féclaz hellfest
armée gens restés tard le soir fait que
la flèche d'or le schiste a créé paussac
c'est un bon trois semaines
trois semaines qui ne connaît peu
puisque c'est pourtant n'avoir rien à
faire
c'est quand monsieur bah la piscine
c'est le fan par une journée un jour
peut-être troisième journée tête année
là était un jour de jeu ce rien que le
cédant une place qui supposément
paradisiaque mais tu le sais pas mais
jamais vu à entre états unis
mais plus haut installé si c'est comme
si elle était l'année
de plus les éliminer il sortait plus ils
s'en allaient faire des activités mes
gestes pas et basculer pour des vraies
c'est quoi maintenant le fer qui arrive
ce genre il y avait la raison pourquoi
il voulait pas qu'on sort c'était parce
qu'il va être citoyen québécois qui voit
quelqu'un que les saignées éliminer ces
cas c'est un stretch quand même là des
tabacs l'ip que quelqu'un te vois toi
aussi sur un scooter plaît à le répéter
l'hymne et puis mettons que salik leur
mettons que sa liquidité faite éliminer
ben ils vont juste le savoir trois
semaines après puis comme tu sais pas
pas le punch du siècle comme le que
d'enlever leur part de l'ucl finalement
c'est celle-là grave
ouais
ouais les feuilles alors vous lancez
votre podcast il faut qu'on s'appelle
s'il ya quelque chose qu'il faut
j'utilise qui est arrivé
je pense que l'analyste ya quelqu'un qui
en a parlé le mais c'est si on avait
fait le job ou est-ce que là c'est vous
qui vous appelez au début parce que
c'est elle marie appelle moi je parle de
quoi même si au début c'était un homme
qui avait fait la voix vous rappelez
damien
alary
on avait pris cette géniale pour le
mettre pour faire un épisode titre parce
que dans le fond comment ça fonctionne
faut déposer le pauc à sa plateforme
pour qu'après sur les plateformes
l'acceptent fait qu'un qu'on allait
faire le lancement les plateformes
allait déjà avoir accepté votre podcast
mais c'est pas se poser le public s'est
pas posé de plus non non non non non non
non avec lui on a mis en abyme pas de
caste mais là n'était pas un ancien camp
avec les personnes qu'il écoute jamais
parce que personne savait c'est quoi le
nom sauf qu'il était faut que ce soit
public vauxois publish pour que les
plateformes accepte une longue sortie
cet épisode leur attendant guillaume
landry vous après la donne
selon le public sur pied leurs yeux
comme eu un problème dans
dans notre communication parce que moi
j'ai comme zenica le guen qu'elle refait
la version avec dom puis post lui
s'endort mutuellement refait la version
avec le vrai jean gol vos voix pipe aux
couleurs mais pousse le 7 juillet pour
lundi quand potter et sorties sauf que à
place de remplacer l'ancienne version
qui était déjà en ligne nicole est juste
posté un nouveau podcast puis publié ce
qui est drôle pour lundi sauf que là ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'on a annoncé le
papier il a tout le monde savait que
cela plaise pour qu'on s'appelle n'y
avait pas encore de partage vers la
chaîne mais il ya à peu près 125
personnes dion et
coûtera quand on remet à la gueule moi
aussi faut constater
mon jardin il ya un hic je sais de la
fin août oui enfin il y avait des câlins
du monde et elle marie le même temps qu
on entend
déjà c'est vraiment un bon mais c'est
aussi la chance de la plus critique
ah oui mais moi je trouvais que ça
faisait j'en vois tu sens une époque a
fait
de même
mais mettons le final
ma tante m'a envoyé comme 5 puis j'ai
pris les homards god
piloté
[Rires]
de trouver
dans la conversation n'est pas bâti ayez
à courir non mais il m'a
fixé et le web change tout est brûlé
jean pauquet centaines de personnes qui
ont subi des pertes et nicole peut faire
jouer nico de tout ce qu'ils font ils le
[Musique]
nom mais c'est incroyable dit moi j'ai
vu sur l'egypte le genre je me suis dit
je vais aussi voir si le pot cassé
disponibles sait d'avancé que je vois
sur les plateformes le jeu vous que
l'épisode est disponible je fais il ya
quelque chose dans ce disque cliquer sur
l'épisode neigeux va voir j'ai
d'ailleurs passé
aouita les allées ici ok
j'ai tellement d'affaires à trac
j'ai tellement d'affaires est racontée
[Rires]
non parce que fini mais s'aggraverait
genre ça commence et vous autres le vous
dit j'aurais voulu parler de moi mais
cela me parler du pot 4 août et après ça
il ya la transition vers ce fait au
moins c'est pas
bon ça me fait penser à preuve en
est
avec moi
ces malades et l'équipe fait que lorsqu
on s'est dit c'est que on allait faire
en deuxième partie de notre podcast ici
on allait faire le concept de votre
podcast qu'on allait prendre des appels
à qui sait les appels qui ont été écrits
sur votre page instagram
s'est dirigé vers
ce mets mois avant que facile et ben
arfa non mais ça c'est pas de faire
booster pour écrire faut qu'on s'appelle
c'est pas pour le savez dans le football
on a pris les trois hommes à la baisse
je veux jouer
davantage et ça fait comme ça fait deux
semaines halfon qu'ils avaient commencé
que les deux étudiants sortis oui
comment que ça se passe comme quand on
s'attendait pas à autant de bons
commentaires on est inquiet du positif
que les gens ne trouvent drôle puis moi
je tairai les noms vont tpe trouvé drôle
oui c'est ma page les drogba mais je ne
veux pas que le montrent le gouffre
voudront pas l'argent mais non quand je
pense à vous avec la peur
de déranger le monde mais parce qu'on
est nous ont habitué de vivre avec nous
maintenant sens qu'on parle comme on
parle aux podcasts on parle 24 sur 24
qu'ils m'entendent pour nous c'est
acquis un peu c'est normal dès demain
mais les gens sont comme content qu'on
sait moins c'est qu'il est monsieur
michael von le mec drôle qu'ils font
mais si ça mais quand c'est la tienne
sur console on est avec toi mais moi ça
fait 25 ans mais bouderont méthode sans
fil
c'est comme le dernier podcast la bulle
dans le deuxième épisode on a parlé des
workaholics alcoolique âgés de 5 et les
gens auraient été imitée elle a lancé
des messages puis moi je me suis fait
écrit aussi les gens étaient émus par ce
sujet là j'ai parlé de ce coin 6 minutes
de soin de moi que l'hymne à la vie pour
moi c'était comme un sujet qui était
quand même normal ça fait partie de ma
vie que j'aime travailler puis ça prend
beaucoup de place les gens on était
vraiment ému de ce lot il conviendrait
que c'est nous les chercher mais cette
foule des enfants il ne pense pas
que tu vas voir comme un impact sur la
journée la personne où aller voter des
gens qui m'ont écrit vraiment et je vois
passer une belle journée c'est j'écoute
et votre podcast ans elle va toucher
comme tel point que le four notre vague
notre énergie vous faites bien même ses
hôtes mais le fun run en bon c'est
vraiment moi c'est ma mère je suis fou
c'est facile pee wee cc rouina c'est un
projet non plus en plus on a la chance
de faire avec vous fait qu'on fait je
sentais bien
fatigués on cela jusqu'à mener large
poutre aux lustres déjà fait pas bon en
[Rires]
fait on est bien
dans ma tête d'homme c'est quoi ce soir
là
dans ma tête je suis en train de
débattre ce jeu là comptez vous
parce que ça inclut quelqu'un cette
personne va sûrement paye tes patins
toute façon pis puis je voir rester
vague qui est sûre les sur les faits
mais on est donc six mois puis un autre
de nos amis on s'est invité à amener à
aller dans un voyage avec des étudiants
de médecine de l'université laval mais
il ya 25 personnes sur les 25 personnes
le single les cinq guingamp coupe un gag
et nous trois célibataires et hérault
puis les vingt deux filles sont toutes
célibataires avec une autre on vole on
fait ce genre comme ça va le crime
en république dominicaine
féclaz en faisant mine a été plombé leur
maman à mes jeunes filles qui veulent
voir notre ami philippe y fait n'était
pas intéressé pantoute ne plaît il fait
savoir qui peut intéresser pantoute
enfin après une couple de jours plus tôt
c'est sûr pas super coup la feuille
vraiment eu sauf que fils n'était pas
plein a mené on va s'asseoir à côté lui
place dans dix neuf ans plus iconiques
comme l'a choisi des plats faits ce qui
fait le sel du même
[Rires]
ensemble personnes qui veulent savoir le
le film puisse pas une question de titre
possible parce que la raison les gens ce
que je veux pas que personne le sache
planorga fait
j'ai des bourses chinoises
trois ans
retourne à tapis comme si nadal est ce
les mêmes ça fait des bulles sort en
boîte le plat il appela ont fait pas
fait j'ai des boules chinoises
c'est pourquoi
moi ça bouge paul l'aiguillé pour - mais
non mais qu'est ce que
mes pauvres et je veux que quelqu'un
m'explique pourquoi est-ce que c'est
sexuel cette chose oui moi je pensais
pas oui c'est sexuel à la base mais
pourquoi ce serait mais moi j'ai lu cela
christian gries le la fia se mettait ça
va se promener le site est haute ça a
payé
c'est jusqu'à maintenant et je sais pas
[Rires]
mais oui accouchement qui vous la
crise
j'ai accouché le talus à la maison plus
j'essayais de faire pipi j'étais plus
capable d'arrêter mopipi acquitté plus
de contrôle seront placés
c'est fou que moi après marathon c'est
rien mais je fais mon marathon à ottawa
mais j'ai chanté sur ma cuisse de quoi
je regarde quand même ci dessus mais
quelquefois l'impact de sortie de t
corey perry sas peur mais je peux
promettre de quoi qui beige il était
trop tard le temps doux qui la matière
on a au marathon qui m'obsède sud c'est
bien plus rien qui marche est
agréable un grand marathon man qu'est ce
qui fait que par là c'est le fun
admettons vraiment c'est vraiment le fun
de t'entraîner pour c'est le fun la
gratification après les 30 premiers
kilomètres sur le fun mais dans tout ce
processus l'oeil de 12 km de cauchemar
dans le fond ah oui au fait que je m'en
fous que tu penses aux travaux qu'est ce
que tu dis je serais pas capable
c'est des fois que je prie pour gens qui
pensent que ton 12 km soit pas y arriver
il ya des boîtes où est ce que je me dis
je me disais mais dont le
jet pack ayant envie de marcher le plus
aimé la honte il faut que je parle dit
jean lassalle est donc quand je
marcherai 6 mai gens l'arrêtent de des
fautes et des fautes étaient pas
capables voie d'évitement il ya de mon
temps mais je n'y arrive 20 derniers
kilomètres quittant matin que les
marches qui sont un peu mes livres mais
moi ce que j'en retiens à ottawa c'est
quand même le
pour arrêter vos flore que mes jambes
des scènes qui ont failli et pai est
tombée à 200 mâ de l'arrivée samia par 5
des chaises roulantes
mais il ya tati conter une histoire
dans le premier podcast pis si nicole
croisille un peu les extraits qu'on veut
mettre sur les réseaux sociaux c'était
le premier podcast et placer l'histoire
ou est ce que tu t'es piscine éclata au
show justin bieber
c'est l'extrait j'ai même pas non non
c'était procès
c'est la main une haie cette anecdote
regardez cet extrait l'eau pour l'heure
publié plus tard parce que c'est
vraiment bon mais je pense qu'on veut
que ce soit
voici le podcast ça va être
maman c'est quoi le plus
fort quand même quand même temps quand
même temps de présenter culte est dir
est facile parce que moi les trois
quatre mois
maintenant pour cent plus
çà et là pour une autre regarde-moi
tosato parfaite 16 0 non mais j'ai par
exemple gilles parent dont j'assume ce
que m'a dit où il est
[Rires]
vrai mais c'est comme sauter sur une
rampe et un trampoline oui
je pensais pas que ça se pouvait avoir
envie mais oui mais oui oui moi je viens
de maman nathalie mais pour pas qu'ils
n'ont
jamais amis qui est pilote d'avion qui
et puis on est allé il m'a amené faire
un petit tour
l'autre jour à québec puis il fait il
fait genre il s'amusait avec le cessna
pile fait j'aurais enfin 0 jill zero
gravity fait kiffer juste drop et le car
elle manque me pisser dessus de moi
là je me disais c'est sûr que c'est
quelqu'un genre lagoutte facile tu
puisses des culottes pas ces gens
n'ont pas le choix de cuillé
[Musique]
non mais
non mais parce que lui il fait mettez un
nom mais un pilote il frappe au sol et
est maintenant à moi de lui demande de
le faire il va pas genre de rappeler
aucune raison faire ça c'est juste que
lui
mais c'est quand même un scanner
bataille c'est pas ça non plus mais ça
feeling la sensation est la glissade
d'eau qu'on avait tardé
ah non ça ferait pas moi ça ne s'est pas
fait à sa manière on est juste a
longtemps lanta québec au fond on fait
juste à embarquer dans charles farine on
était on était au tournage des gens d'un
tournage ce qu'elle montre à travailler
puis après ça on avait comme du temps à
tuer glander on a comme petacchi et
cyclones d'aller à montréal finalement
on nomme de la calypso à
calypso maquis kenexa delaveau qui conte
les mains hors de contrôle
pisa et j'aime et moi
c'est comme un rabais tube le type le
tout la pop 32 dans ce nom du freedom
été comme de boujan non pileux les
planches effet jugé s'ouvrent et se
ferment oui le titan bas verticale le
tpiy liste des quatre côtés john tu
tombes longtemps islamabad
mais comme à pauline bien dans ce mail
ou pl c'est le faible au plus tard hime
jarre le mama keita chute libre le
4e temps des pommes et on veut leur
offrir aucune je sais c'est quoi
peut-être c'est moins péméja rester
comme ça se trouve c'est qu'on rentre
dans l'eau on sera au regard des risques
c'était quoi le faire van damme le mash
up le mot je suis genre en mode c'était
la chose la plus débile au mans puis le
tout le monde autour de moi ce jardin
monsieur qui sont membres les bras
croisés à l'ademe des affaires personne
a l'air de trouver que c'est une scène
moi je veux ou d'hommes exposé arrivée
blocs à karim n'en ait contact des
enfants
[Rires]
j'ai comme envie de crier mais en même
temps tout le monde et j'adore
la première fois avec vous avez cet
incident les rangs à l'instar de panique
est meilleure mais c'est quentin vite
paniqué dans la zone place ou sur
personne pas nous
inquiéter vraiment mais wells aux usa
mais le basket était bon c'est tout ce
que je te dis oui non mais c'est
l'excitation de me trouver bonne mais
devant les enfants 4 ans passe à côté
elles sont lancées à 4 ans d anormal
ouais il est question d'avoir une
énergie genre qu'on la demande pas pour
le moment j'étais allé voir amener à
l'intérieur à québec un un showdown mais
ben révéré qui s'appelle silversun
pickups six ans même quand même
indépendant attire vraiment faute et
coûteux laitiers mais moi j'ai réécouté
ça à côté je connaissais paroles par
coeur or ça me touche et leur musique
puis j'arrive à l'impérial tout le monde
sort d'un pilote par curiosité
plage ou m'étonne que celle m juste en
face j'ai envie de hurler puis de cuillé
les paroles qu'il a remarqué chris miles
à tout le monde et comme tout le monde
chez les
gens
jamais
vraiment dans ma tête j'ai goût de
partir à rire de rides rapidement
emparés gens-là de l'afl la danse à
mais au moins dix contient pas ce qu'il
ya mais au fond - dalphond portée des
fois des fois dans les chaudes mort là
maintenant il ya tout le temps une
personne et la jeune
haoua y avait une finale elle a brisé
mon spectacle n'en sais rien
mais je n étais qu homme était dans nos
oreilles l'été la range à maria pia qui
y est c'est pas fait pour a
annoncé des moments vraiment jamais
chaque mois l autre jour
non
en fait si on les appelle
oui ça serait bon google veut tuer
l'élue
à l'eau les faits il en est le
légitime
j'ai 26 ans et je viens tous les deux
finalistes de finaliser une technique en
hygiène dentaire j'ai commencé sur le
marché du travail depuis peu mais j'ai
le pressentiment de ne pas vraiment fort
ce qui me passionne
14 d'une technique cqeer simple j'aime
mon travail mais on dirait que j'aurais
envie de voyager de faire quelque chose
de créatif ou de lancer ma propre
business qu'est le feeling en même temps
j'ai envie de m'acheter une maison
d'abord une petite famille avec mon
copain il m'a début trentaine et le
respect toute façon
je pense que les réseaux sociaux ont une
grosse part dans ses questionnements sur
l'aide parce que je me compare beaucoup
avec tous les gens qui sont juste
voyager et faire le party alors que je
suis dans ma routine quotidienne
ordinaire
ceci est vrai qu'ils posent à la pause
là dessus parce que tout le temps si
tchèque les réseaux sociaux le tout
toujours l'impression de passer à coup
de tête tout en le formant le big show
sauf eu tellement pour l'avoir fait un
peut maintenant aller en voyage de
réseaux sociaux le a est en rien le fond
et j'avais fait
ça là la femme était à coursan deux
squats de photos plutôt bien personne
qui va partager genre me voici à 9
heures au bureau sur mon fichier excel
genre tous les jours
la routine ça fait des moins bonnes
photos mais
quelque chose de ridicule
les moments parce que je suis plus je me
sens le plus accompli mais je me sens de
plus comme je y at il un jour ça va bien
mais à force et
cantine puis jorge j'ai l'impression
qu'à chaque jour je travaille pour
quelque chose je m'approche de mon but
n'était voyages
feeling mais c'est la routine c'est
comme si moi c'est que c'est un genre
montrer mais qu'est ce
que je trouve carrément intéressant le
sic et mettons les voyages d'influencer
les mettons le pour faire d'influencé
autour du monde si le voyage mais dans
le foot et le pour t'évader te reposer
puis voyage et puis pour travailler je
comprends que ceux qui voient les
poteaux genre et tourisme et l place
mais ton fut jamais de travailler facto
non c'est cameron a voyagé qui s'est
évadé jean pical comme décroche insee ça
c'était pas de vacances
c'est juste qu'on la voit pas inzaghi
des métiers de comme l'oeuf avant que
j'avais vu
ça fait longtemps et c'était genre même
la fille dans le magazine avait
ressemblé à filles dans le magazine be -
chose mais c'est tellement ce thème
émeutes ont travaillé dans ce domaine
depuis en fait des fois des voyages je
regarde ses voyages et puis comme qu'est
ce que je fais assez souvent dans le
bourg jean py fait face à ces défis des
deux lois des réseaux sociaux de pas
envie qu'ils ont
pu tisser ce type le vouloir construire
ta famille puis avoir une maison se pile
aussi voyager mais le fatah tekna
quelque chose puis flamand prime est
souple et retournent aux études c'est
que tout ceci est valable c'est juste
que tu peux
moi je trouve pas qu'on dirait trois
villes différentes choses juste que
c'est comme la lune bonnes bases à lui
fait cercueil en jean un événement tant
pis le kesk havre puis probablement
qu'est-ce qui l'a faufile sur le long
terme ça va être sa maison avec sa
famille sauf cas le dans l'instant
besoin de voyager parce que sur mac app
en ce cas le pot à ces fêtes de trucs
mais je pense que je sais c'est pas trop
avis différent en ce sens que
non mais si je pense que c'est de se
mettre une pression top-5 à leur faire -
réponse est d'aller faire un voyage à
bord de son voyage avec un peu mieux
dans le sens qu'avorter hockey tchèque
j'ai fait le début et ça sera l'année
prochaine un prochain voyage prix de
farce 45 100e but est d'être tout le
monde
[Musique]
a des fois nettement moins béton quand
je pars en voyage afin que voyageur de
revenir à t apporte montant qui compte
comme tu dis à ta routine qui fait que
travailleur quelque chose parce que
rapidement vraiment que juste genre en
de goa voyage d'un tweet comme un peu de
thann et puis pas avoir l'impression de
travailler vers quelque chose mais il ya
fort intéressant à ce qu'a dit c'est que
allait me reste à faire quelque chose de
créatif ou de lancer sa propre business
c'est
sûr qu'après le monde s'élance une job à
s'étendre les génisses dentaire mince
tant messi
au programme jazz comme ça jobs horaire
normal qu'ils procréative puis kippour
entrepreneuriat le ton ouais mais chaque
à plein de monde qui ont eu cette
expertise cette espèce d'idée car et
c'est quelque chose de créatif ou deux
mais ça c'est quand même tempère algérie
le oui c'est en vue l'homme est tombé
moi je trouve ça quand même mais je
voulais du temps tôt et mieux c'est
quand même vraiment impressionnant
quelqu'un qui est créatif dans vicky
capable de voir quelque chose dans un
ipod le mythe d'un vrai vie fait contre
exploit quelque chose que je néglige les
débats oui c'est d'avancer
je trouve que c'est un chacun peut
imaginer deux là préfèrent les deux
bassins fait ça c'est au pca les sept
sites en ville et d'être entreprenants
qu'il fasse en même temps les tiges et
ouais c'est ça puis tiens on entend
souvent des tons l'espèce de picking
déjà au top c'est un plan b qui n'ont
pas de plan maintenant oui j'ai mangé un
bon ami à moi julien rodriguez
same as beaucoup dans une pique à damas
compagnie lui ya un podcast qui appelle
le journal de l'entrepreneur superbe au
podcast pour les entrepreneurs en
devenir la risée des seuils c'est
vraiment bon puis dans son bas de casse
du lait c'est pauvre jobs 9 à 5 j'en
suis la pire erreur réforme si vous
lancez un business le arrête tes potes
tout lançait pas tout par la fenêtre
gardez vous une gerbe de façade qui va
faire que vous allez mieux
financièrement vous allez avoir un
meilleur moral vous n'êtes jamais et à
côté de vous et dans le fond après
safran souhaite il y aura un revenu ou
se classe ainsi un chercheur mais genre
laissez pas votre job c'est vrai que
c'est compatible wii all in ti mousse
est très déçue que de rêver les gens
suivent metronomy passion pige en direct
et son aptitude à musique est juste et
mais
il faut quand même être réaliste faut
quand même payer ça bouffe dassier en a
pas
j'encourage tout le monde à suivre ses
rêves mais juste il faut quand même se
pose la question de comment ça se
traduit dans le monde réel typiquement
tu veux faire en sorte que ça va
vraiment arriver puis tout être capable
de vivre le triplé mettons le kilo qui
passionne les gens peuvent vivre la
musique le mais qu' il manque d'argent
mettons pas ce qu'il fait pas chaud le
tue le vip autant bien le tapas sont
enviées par ce qui est expressif du
problème et toute la vie quittant mon
sacrum non ces deuxièmes sa passion le
saint jean comme un ouïgour il le faut
que j'en passe des choses dans la vie
c'est pas mieux ses factures c'est ce
show qui passe cette affaire d etat
chaudement de travail ou contrat
justement je fais de la musique mais la
personne à pratiquer un travail pas son
truc c'est qu'on sait c'est comme je
vais faire si
il a déjà fait sa demande et pas juste
une belle idée et femmes ans de travail
ctt magnification c'est enfin un plein
je me compare beaucoup avec tous les
gens qui semblent justes voyager faire
la partie alors que je suis là ma
routine quotidienne en savons un peu
dans tous les sens j'ai lu que ce que je
dis je ne sais pas si vous me suivez
pour l'instant ça va la trentaine arrivé
j'ai peur de regretter de ne pas avoir
vécu ma jeunesse ou de ne pas avoir
choisi un emploi qui passionne peu
d'enfants essentiellement on s'ennuyait
va
répondre à cette situation là mais si ce
site off
s'étoffe c'est of pi des fois il faut
faire des sacs et des fois faut faire
des sacrifices à 100 ce qui m'est on
s'écoute à un ordre de priorité six
jours avant la carrière dans quel but de
sa complice folk séparation puis c'est
là dedans titres valorisés ou sap ottawa
la résidente adjointe amène sécurité
puisqu'il vallauris et ta famille août
ces importantes ou si le voyage métier
ça se paye ta peau tout ça spectacle
quelque chose puis que la job ce plus
alimentaire mais qui est vraiment ta
vraie passion c est avec le monde que tu
aimes puis avoir vu ta famille ton
talent dans tbilissi mettons on la lit
le temps quelqu'un qui peut la vivre
comme ça valait vraiment toutes dans le
sens calais bonne job le ca peut faire
une famille avec théa le tout mais des
fois on regarde ce qu'on veut ce qu'on
est peu mais sûrement kalapo prix temps
de regarder ce cas lui en ce moment
puisque des images et tout ce qu'est ce
que je peux ajouter une enfant provoc je
suis bien je pense que c'est ce qui
manque avec comme tout cas le pense
moment juste nommé une affaire qu'elle
est peut-être que sa fac et il ya un
truc l'escarcelle si je me compare
beaucoup plus aussi
[Musique]
[Rires]
arrêter de se ré c'est vrai parce que sa
flûte il reste en hausse des prix en
ligne
s'est quand même passé quelque chose oui
ils font c'est pourtant ce que tu veux
mais je sais salah est repassé commande
est passée présente et paix ou si le
monde ouais mais donne de la valeur à
sous
mais
je me ramène tout le temps scratch comme
je vais pas pourquoi je le nomme et
loser il faut tout le temps je me disais
je voudrais même pas failli ce art eyed
peas est quand même surprenant dans ma
vie vous je me dise ont moins de trois
fois sa main de facile mais kenzy fond
on va le faire consciemment pour celle
du peuvent axa tournant dans la tête ça
fait partie
comme cinq ans il derrière déjà il
servait de l'iphone
ton voyage le team est un ovni reprenant
cet exemple le piégeage est tombé à
charritte de voyage et ça va de la
malade en novembre
et qui dans le fond à réalité qui est
évidemment le sait mais les mêmes moyens
un qu'il sait ce qu'ils rentrent dans
tout mais moi qui le sait des fois je me
surprends à regarder quelque chose sur
instagram perd 4 même salaire tim et ont
pu même quand j'étais célibataire mais
dont je regardais je regardais des
filles sur instagram le plus fréquemment
mais cette espèce du genre tu imagines
une relation avec cette personne le
pleurer
comme iman
aucune chance que ce soit une relation
sincère des patoisants fait genre était
comme attiré vers la foi tout genre oui
en même temps aime ce genre ça me
tenterait c'est la dernière chose au
monde derrière les décisions de la vie
c'est dessus
cette relation-là ce genre de personne
lifestyle
lever le matin
une photo des fesses de table ont depuis
lors m g comme suit vraiment su ce que
tu veux dans la soirée dans le bas de
l'allée fun mais j'en conviens soir dans
le but
de faire des choix des tequilas que des
amis à renoncer à la rote mais à quel
point à l'intérieur et j'ai envie
d'aller au warehouse mes paniers des
chats d'été qu'ils
ont tué jaurès à petit on a parlé hier
de schengen
chez agathe et plus tu voi momméja ton
qu'une envie d'être le rendant dans le
vip hier des photos
je veux écouter le choc lorsque tu vois
de commun ça va les rattacher à gosses
et les autres n'ont pas eu le même trip
que tu aurais voulu avoir le c c'est fou
c'est que se comparer puis imaginez
forces armées forexpros steve hackett
analyse vraiment c'est quoi ma vie c'est
quoi leur vie c'était chanceux quand
même parce qu'elle est on parle
d'enfants j'y mets ton voyage puis vip h
et le expérimenté puis si tu es capable
de dire jean bosmans bon chien qui vont
à chicago sur mac aime rester dans le
vip mais jamais coule dans le vieille
ville sait-on jamais rien à gijon pour
directement sur le bayern à la société
seuls 80 ans bcc peut on et chansons
l'expérimenté ouais quand même 9 2 day
qu'est-ce
que c'est power ce qu'on pense t'il un
moment son image titre over dis que
c'est vraiment ces femmes at il eu pour
comme tout le monde c'est jusqu'à menton
le toit et la lombarde à 4 ou 6 e c'est
juste qu'il est moins pagny c'est tout
puis on ne sait pas non plus qu est-ce
qui va derrière c'est maintenant
cela-dit genre le monde qui ont juste
l'air sur le parti ou juste l'air de
voyages étiez mais ce monde là des fois
leur mettons ils voyagent pluies sont
dans le rouge pour le reste du mois
parce que ils ont toutes basées sur
leurs voyages sur leur part les gens ils
manquent le bottier pon moun pa lé staff
on voit ce qu'elle est il faut qu'ils
faut qu'ils vivent leur vie pour être
capable de payer leur appart tel mais
c'est tellement parce que beaucoup de
monde qui qui gagnent leur vie avec avec
seulement 9 y en a mais il y en a pas à
l'infini leur vexé à g puis avec thé
mais ce monde là il ya tout un autre job
ils ont tous quelque chose d'autre
voyant restauration puis en 35 ans et
travaille en restauration puis une fois
qu'un set à g va mourir qu'est ce qui se
passe avec ta carrière qu'est ce qui se
passe ici car je sais la fille et que
canal aux primaires le clergé qui
comptables non j'avais comme ça oui
c'est juste une question de temps passe
et elle checks des réseaux sociaux puis
a tout le temps de la
backstage avec ti est ou à las vegas ou
à miami dentelle à faire des piges à
c'est la fille comptable travail george
sanders men qui sort une fois par deux
semaines à avant une fin de semaine à
las vegas ou à miami pigeât médecine
c'est comme ça mais c'est jade la dette
je sais
sa dette jusqu'à sa vie mais c'est pas
ça sa vie mais c'est tout un arrière
d'être ce qu'on voit pas on
l'a regardé un peu au podcast notre fac
parce qu'on est donc constamment c'est
fou vraiment
pas ce qu'on
a fait
concentre toi allez un petit rebond
présent tout le consensus et non pas toi
quand on écoute moi
mais quand sarthois sur ce qu'il arrête
de te comparer puis un autre bon point
et c'est de voir une affaire que tu
pourrais ajouter à ta vie dans le fond
puis je pense que c'était quand même un
bon conseil maintenant quand je dis si
c'est parce que j'ai été longtemps comme
ça à tout vouloir mais finalement je me
regarde je commun mais j'ai déjà tout
dans le sens bourg est bien peu de
réussite et puis quand je dis tout à
voir ça peut parler de matériel autant
de gens tiennent la maison nano si je
veux tout en même temps tout le temps là
quiz pour ce que je dis c'est parce que
moi même je me sens super
production américaine - c'est le fameux
l'herbe plus verte chez le voisin
c'est vraiment moi maintenant maintenant
je commets une place que je comme il ya
des gens avancent que la
wii ses cinq métiers
justement entier ttt d'asie plus stable
tu veux plus de liberté des piles est
peut-être un peu de liberté tu voudrais
plus de revenus peut-être qui a été ta
relation de soude rethel bat date est
une battante et en relation manif aussi
fou comme
trop questure et puis tout le tibet le
[Musique]
merdier
salanon
tellement la
femme à la parata comme ça
j'adore jouer qu'à man on amène aujourd
hui si vous voulez
première saison de ta grossesse allen
voici mon témoignage j'ai 32 ans et je
suis enceinte de trois mois et demi je
pensais trop bébé je tais le nom
trop débile
ça coulait qu'on retient depuis trois
ans maintenant c'est rencontrer un
moment où les deux on voulait exactement
la même chose trouver la bonne personne
de fonder une famille good son pinceau
que
tout est vraiment parfait
pour est
excellente et moyens
seule chose c'est qu'il travaille
énormément bien douze de ces partir sa
propre compagnie il fait absolument rien
côté ménages et tâches ménagères
je n'ai pas de problème en faire plus vu
que je travaille moins et pas 90 % 10 %
n'en met pas moins la shem le
[Musique]
dpi shape
je travaillais mais voilà j'espère c'est
probablement que lui hier soir est un
travail bénévole aussi
c'est vrai les deux ont travaillé à la
brousse tegel
on va peut-être leur roster matin devant
l
on va peut-être leur aussi parce que le
thé quand vous prenez la décision
d'avoir un enfant c'est peut-être pas le
meilleur moment pour comme tenant une
business qui va pas te rapporter de
salaire à vingt trois a
[Rires]
paru le plus
on a rencontré jean
louis
gardel anecdotes tout nu dans la rue à
l'écouté pour qu'on s'appelle pour
ses propres armes et en faire plus il
travaille moi je les présenterai ma
blonde qui se
voilent excuses qu'il n'a pas l'attaqué
lorsque
françois m'excuse n'a pas le temps il
que lorsque baby va mener doit
s'améliorer et moins travailler et
c'est vrai que j'ai plus de temps mais
on dirait que je trouve je ne trouve pas
ça juste
j'ai comme l'impression que d'espérer
que ça change d'un coup ce n'est pas
réaliste
le poteau comment ça se passe pour vous
dans votre relation au niveau des tâches
ménagères comment gérer ça au quotidien
merci au monde j'aime faire tout
[Rires]
fonctionne comme n'importe qui mais
comme tous mes amis charles tout conflit
social mais
c'est sûr qu'il fait plus que le miel
[Rires]
mais c'est vrai il fait tout
signalé par des podiums mais pas ceux
qui depuis la semaine passée
genre le gaillard il un
nombre de ménages dans son
jeu latin
comme ceux qui creusent le
nom mais
chut bâton
malaisie je vous laisse parler sur ce le
même mois il ya un an x qui m'énerve
dans la séparation de touche mais là je
veux parler pour ma relation qui femme
avec qui et
puis c'est que j'ai l'impression qu'ils
aiment tant on n'est pas tant conscient
des tâches qui sont plus pour je fais
vraiment des guillemets pour les hommes
attention la fréquence est lié au fait
qu'on parle d'eux on parle de notre
expérience expérience
des conventions ont été reçus changer
poubelle
mais c'est que maintenant moi je peux tu
as conscience de toutes les tâches de go
que je l ai fait la france ouais passé
louis victor et tiji prend même pas
connaissance de ces tâches le au
quotidien puis lui prend sûrement pas
connaissance que je lave les toilettes à
chaque semaine ce qui fait qu'ils aient
dit je trouve que s'ils peuvent le dire
on fait vraiment 55 ans on n'est pas les
deux conscients de tout ce que l'autre
fait dans sa vie petit jeu vos potagers
ils avaient peur est aujourd'hui il faut
qualité non
mais mon objet qu'est ce qui marche bien
c'est qu'on ne les deux notes liste de
tâches qui nous fait chier puis qu'on
veut absolument pas fait ça me dérange
de fer puis on le donne à l'autre piquer
ses bâtons réalité de la poubelle et
aucune chance je trouvais ça m'écoeure
est-ce que vous avez acte est ce que
vous avez fait une liste mais laisse
complète de l'été non non ça je suis
naturel oui mais mais c'est un bon point
ce que tu dis des fois parce que ceux
effectivement
avec moi ça m'est jamais arrivé parce
que mes relations tout en toute fin 90
dollars c'est tout le temps d accès à ce
niveau là mais mais
maintenant j'en faisais vraiment tout le
temps plus le dessus parce que pourtant
c'est ça mais j'imagine comme ça c'est
vrai que tente une maison aux cantons
une relation de longue durée il doit
avoir des torches qui de base se dit
ville selon qui les fais le tu sais que
ben la piscine qui fait le gazon qui
fait ses affaires lotis mais inversement
tu le vois pas parce que c'est peut-être
un bon point que tu es là bas est le
geste peuvent attaquer la pensée 90 10
mais qu'au final lui fait des affaires
qu'elle avait juste pour me voyais cela
il ya aussi le fait que est ta maison je
pense qu'elle a dit dis
[Musique]
lui ce sera triste
que je travaille moins c'est que je
travaille quand même et je travaille la
maison si ça fait que le lave vaisselle
ni plus à portée de main mais c'est la
monte young à montréal fait que ceux ci
ça bien aussi je sais pas quand même
mais plus l'eau en béton pour les
niveaux tant je pense que tu as
l'impression que tu ta maison fait petit
doigt pietà brasse équipe rythme mais
c'est sur ces mots ce mot commence à me
droguer que mon ami me dit que je
pourrais en faire plus c'est que
l'espace et le temps fait tout un petit
peu vite et tout à fait plus sa maison
kloet et lui à la présente un fait moins
crue oui c'était un coup bas
puis tout représente ainsi passer quoi
je sais quoi l'enfant non mais je pense
pas que les deux femmes allongées moi
non non pas moi je vois aliments scotia
lé dessus comme d'hab et non pas tout
maintenant je parle mais je pense pas
qu'il dirait que je fais est affilié non
ouais j'en fais moins que lui mais je
pense que j'ai le sentiment d'en faire
plus parce que tu es toujours remise
mais pas toujours nié mais que les fans
des capitaux qu ils savent ce que je
pense des sentiments en faire plus parce
que je suis plus souvent maison des
toits yeux taka sens commun 90 qui pète
un soin sans doute plus qu'un kit à
maison puis le qui fait toutes les
tâches plus réparer sa sphère la nana na
na na hey lui a l'impression qu'ils en
fait fools ouais c'est ça va ce qui
arrive de ce qui arrive chez eux il
tomba il pense que c'est se poser rien
il se pose est en mode détente chose la
main
mais il est quand même l'aspect puis je
les mentionnaient paralysé le yml mais
de seulement 100 business qu'un petit en
train de fonder une famille c'est quand
même un stade se lance en business vous
le savez le titre c'est quand tu arrives
pas de table rapidement le c'est long
quand même ça prend du temps pis s'il ya
bien un moment dans la vie où est ce que
tu vas être financièrement stable stable
c'est quand un enfant qui s'en vient du
coup votre expérience avec eux parce que
moi mettons nous mettons que je planifie
avec ma blonde de fraude avons un enfant
j'attendrai d'être un moment où est-ce
que sur les business fonctionne nous
lancer un nouveau projet quand ça arrive
je suis là dessus dans ce sens que moi
je veux dire la journée que ton enfant
vont être si vous avez la chance
d'expérimenter c'est aussi vous voulez
qu'ils veulent voir si votre tout faire
peu importe ta stabilité financière tu
veux être comme moi c'était ça mon
feeling jolie vue puis commis pour et
ben ma maison pour aimer brûlés ou
disparaître demain matin je suis je veux
trouver une façon parce que c'est lui
qui savait tout pour le reste de ma vie
fake que tu me dirai demain matin les
réseaux sociaux arrêt je prendrais quand
même si j'aurais gardé cet enfant
loucheur j'en voudrais un deuxième quand
même vous
parce que
entre temps avec les priorités dans la
vie on parlait de tulle moi c'est
vraiment famille amour à me pisser
s'appuie je pense va tout faire pour
manager ouais ouais
je peux je peux pas réfléchi non plus
j'en parle souvent la phrase ça c'est
des amis à moi des gens autour qui me
voient depuis longtemps être maman tout
50,3 me pieds sont comme des pays
proches dans ses errements gens toutes
mes amies ont des bons travail sort de
l'université ont des jobs justement des
façades qui est stable qui leur apporte
une sécurité venant sabine disent tout
je me sens à peu près financièrement
avoir un enfant mais crime caisse mais
le plan qu'est-ce qui est besoin de ça
c'est de la moquerie comme puce a6
l'avons pas son vrai que ça coûte un
million un enfant le micro tavi vois
bien aller ton enfant voit bien à vie si
toi tu vois bien puisque comme ça c'est
vraiment venir commencent à bien une
dignité d'enfants
c'est pareil on jamais été la famille
qui ont frôlé d'argent mais on construit
mais c'est une rime entier pour ne pas
servir tout le temps tu atteins safety
net aussi si jamais tout chine met en
garde que moi c'est comme ça dans ma vie
avec mes mara mais c'est si jamais à me
to cheek je peux appeler maman maman oui
j'ai besoin de cette voie j'ai besoin de
mes parents ils me parlent en sept mois
que mon bébé qui arrive et tu vois une
change elizavety mais c'est se rendrait
comme tu dis oui il ya toujours
quelqu'un en erreur qui te fait qu un
santé qui était correctement à
saint-sauveur mon pied à terre ma
sécurité à l'endroit n'était pas les
choses et paul minn
il ya toujours quelqu'un wii qui va
t'apporter cette sécurité le mais
d'avoir un enfant oui peut-être que dans
l'autre des parents pas trop loin des
grands par ex en présence après des
temps que ça arrive que ce potin le
câble ont depuis
petit bouton home où allez-vous ça
arrive tu es tu puisses pas prévu je
pense que je pense que forcément on
finit toujours par site et on s'arrange
pige dans sa marche et puis on trouve
des solutions peu mais mettons quand tu
mois maintenant mais ton jeu peut
commencer si marion thomas c'est dans ma
tête on essaie de garder on
s'arrangerait puis
mais si on ne planifie ça sera sympa
l'autre ça va peut-être justement qu'un
contexte web un petit peu meilleure que
je peut justement
être capable de faire un revenu etc
c'est en travaillant
un peu moins en étaient en plus leur
présence
c'est ça parce que lui dans le fond dans
son histoire c'est qu'il semble
travailler à l'infini puis ça c'est sûr
que c'est sûr qu'ils apprécient aussi la
tente c'est l'autre aspect de son
message tient qui dit qu'en cas pense
que lui va changer quand l'enfant va
arriver non c'est pas lui qui va décider
le site normand sa besace qui va
disputer s'ils changent pita bon il en
faudrait qu'on pense que jean
d'accoucher mais ta vie est changée
pilote non a viré cela - jusqu'à ton
enfant dessus dans ta vie ton enfant
plus atypique des cinq de plus à traîner
un coq et a traîné mais ta vie reste la
même ta conscience et la main mt des
choses qui changent mais avoue qui est
toujours l'homme n'était pas devenu
genre à l'anis numéro deux a évolué mais
des bulles à bord avec ton enfant je
trouve qu'ils étaient la pire personne
ne lui ait maintenant avec mes roues
j'ai fait la fête en commun cela plus
moins eu un manque de la plus sud du
mans mais avec j'ai
quand même fait mais même les gueules
c'est la gestion le tient de voir
tableau souffrir comme streiff frey toi
aussi tu dors moyen
de rentrer dans n'importe quelle
situation
avec une condition c'est toujours
mauvais c'est fait que ella diehl
mettons cas s'accroche à ce que lui dit
qu'il va changer plus tard le soc est
une recette pour un désastre c'est qu'il
rentre à duration petit chien en plus
c'est comme une fois de plus une fois
que cette chicane le va être réglé ça va
bien aller une fois que ça s'arrête
regus a bien voyagé sur un paquebot
jamais vrai jamais vrai fait citer une
condition si elle dans sa tête c'est
genre oh mais quand je vais avoir le
bébé ça va être mieux oblige on oublie
ça arrive au poste mais si en plus ils
disent avoir un enfant c'est
amplificateur des tees émotion que
ceux-ci vraiment vrai mais donc une
journée tout à fait un dépôt soit encore
plus maintenant tout tout tout
financièrement d'état côté son enfance
et applicateurs tête à côté plus actifs
si ces sites outre avec le stress au
taux s'applique comme néfaste lucidi qui
va changer a dit
qu'il savait plus s'il voit je sais plus
si c'est vraiment c'est simplificateur
s'il pense que dans six mois ça business
qui va être plus lourd sur un peu je te
garantis qui fait travailler beaucoup
laissé bien plus
si dans ta tête ça se passe la raison
c'est tout un monde qui travaille
vraiment foule je tends le monde qui
travaille pas tant pis si ce taux est un
trouble mental en est le travail travail
et emploi travaillé non-stop
ramassées dans des situations tout le
temps qui tue mouches ces personnes là
avec ses je sais de quoi je parle mettez
des trucs tu as traversé à côté
travailler à valence le genre les fois
que je t'ai entendu c'est parce que tant
d'hommes le nombre de fois je
l'entendais parce que quand on pensait
arrêter le sang filtre adam et puis
ces deux hommes avaient le projet de
lanceur pas de cas ce type le secam
québec comme nice n'ont pas cassé couple
c'est carole dans le temps en mai je
pense peu différents métiers le mois de
juin et je dois être plus le joueur le
temps la presse a pu mais noah de
s'appeler fait non métis moi aussi je
tâte et même le mois de juillet le losc
doit être luz lors le tabou c'est quand
même cool le tarif en juillet le gicam
même tous les actifs achetés à côté mais
le mois d'août lol moi d'où c'est pas
mal moi que tu es le plus occupé
erreurs et après ça gâche leur faut
respirer la joie être loupé le taximan
dix contre dix mais l'avoir plus est
quand même
ça fait deux amis chaque mot que tu
dises ça va être dur là
on réussir parce que c'est ce puissant
ou couvrir et laisser mon mois - qui
paie tout mots doux et je me suis fais
pas ta chatte qui na na na pi elle a
bien fait comme prévu des méharistes
a compté 1 contre photo il faut jamais
perdre y arrivait toujours à côté
car de type comme tête à côté c'est le
bilan
que tu dises ou pau que tu cherches à
tous politiques vont être lui faut il
que ce truc là ça change pas à moins que
tu répondes
pour les problèmes spock et la job
halles à paris le 6 août sidibé à tous
mais oui j'ai par la cabab oui je pense
et agit comme la
contrainte
non moi je suis pas de chanter à trois
heures pique tout est bon à simon
passion et
mon enfance et qui est à l'arrêt jamais
mon podium arrive contexte les gens
s'accordent maintenant à s'inquiéter
sur répondu ouais
mais comme nantes et tendres étaient à
rythme techs passant le score mais c'est
vraiment ce qui est incroyable c'est ce
qui est incroyable puis un jour alors
blog et julien aaron encore là parce que
j'écoute mon podcast puis donne vraiment
des bons conseils les pluies avaient
quant à eux lancé beau livre suppléments
et avait ce problème le des genres ya eu
8 heures un samedi soir d'un suspect de
famille le jeune défenseur est écrit pis
tu tu vois la notification fait que le
sait pas qui l'a vu tu réponds avec le
bus qui a fait c'est que c'est acheter
deux self qui en selle le job qu'il
laisse au bureau bien celle de vie
privée fait qu'un kit or de beaux livres
à 5 heures mais las il ya peu ce que
plus on sait le job s'est classé ja
l'oeil sur mon nouveau c'est juste mes
amis qui ma famille qui peut marge en
pis non y'a rien qui rendu là jobs
est mort au wtc sopi au final tu montes
fonds se sont pas d'amuser enfance
quelle crise lorient n'est pas la mise
en récit ces jeunes en plus laissés
tard en réalisant que tout
comme à manquer tout le temps de tout
métier la forme et on les considère se
plongea ans selon un peu de son message
le mais quand tu considères me tombe
dessus cette illumination lui
répond à un message à chaque fois que je
reçois un message ça prend un temps et
fait faute tu te reconnais que ton gmail
faute sur lizeroux qui lisent les
messages ou tout répond le message tulle
en voiture
si tu accumules dit ce message
le lundi matin à 8h ou 9h ou alors que
tu veux commencer à répondre usage est
assurément ton ordi ton du maire n'a
tant pis tu réponds à toutes les
messages one shot ça va te prendre 50%
du temps par message que si tu répondais
à chaque fois que tu joues le message
rentrée fait également mieux de faire
sur ces thèmes que de jeter parce que
jusque là le message rendre le tout en
mode business tu penses à ton à la fois
juste leymergie mental tu réponds
messages sur des postures ce message
l'effort de faire se lisent en ligne est
au complet le lendemain matin
de la projection manqué je fais d'abord
parce que vraiment quand les gens
m'écrivent mettant le temps le matin
puis le toute la journée je te soutenons
la chine joue même pas mes courriers je
vois les rouvrir le lendemain matin mais
ils vont en avoir écrit deux autres
messages appris
au monde dirigé par on dit ahmad un
message fort en moyenne 24 heures c'est
que tu t'en fous des thèmes malaguti
d'habitude à
une projection c'est quelqu'un du
camarade était celle ci a commencé à
d'été tu réponds tout le temps dans deux
minutes toi ce que tu reçois le texto la
personne va être quoi s'attendre à ce
que tu répondes en deux minutes la fois
où est-ce que tu répondes repas en deux
minutes parce que x ou y à fort à va
sentir que yann marez il ya ba comme de
prêter des intentions le fait que moi
activement mettons en début de relation
le jour un message rentrée il loge prend
du temps avant de répondre don mello
dargelès coûter plus cher aux plats
amenés sait comment oui c'est vrai
j'avais su je vous réponds le tout
répond comme ses yeux comme à moi si tu
as aimé aussi voulu gel voire en afrique
en 20 ans j'étais pas là mais c'est
voulu c'est vraiment la chose de tes
clients
mais là je vais t'apprendre et stx et
toi tu me tues me volant sport avant 24
ore ce qu'est ce qui me fait plus chier
que ces mêmes pages en mettant
vraiment drôle parce que notre sujet des
beats podcast qu'on va tourner après
c'est de ce qu'on voulait parler des
feux pilier ben écoutez ce qui nous
accueillent vous avez écouté leurs côtés
trois épisodes pour la suite à quoi
faire si vous
l'avez de dundo
l'évêque a présenté mardi
mais c'est qu'il sait jamais des enfants
qui l'ont sauvé le monde et ces gens une
maman qui veut ces photos de famille le
petit à roche et le jardin sont à de
famille avec son occupant parce qu' elle
a vu ses photos this
way sultani plus jamais une question de
vie ou de mort mais si c'est vraiment la
chose qui me permet de décrocher plus ne
s'est jamais fait ça mais jamais
quelqu'un en danger que je te réponds
dans deux jours ou dans l'eau mais non
puis c'était mais là je vais arrêter
paris puisque je remporte les plus tôt
avec karine mais dans mes vacances
maintenant le théâtre fois que je
prenais une semaine de vacances j'aime y
aurait un message et aux marchés c'est
sa première fois les moves c'était fou
mendy l'homme et avec un des clients qui
belicchi à des compagnies qui me crever
je sais que tu es en vacances mais
doit-on courriel et réponse du juge
comme il
y avait une compagnie partenaire
sexuel à qui écrivent et puis j'ai écrit
à mon contact là bas puis à la vie à la
mort un moyen messages automatiques et
monsieur perdu de telle heure à telle
date soit en vacances puis je ne
répondrai pas à mes courriels et vous
devriez faire la même chose
georges et un accès limité à mes
courriels elle s'est juste comme je
regarderai pas
pour pour faire une synthèse de ce qu'on
a dit le personnel première chose si tu
attends ce que ça change obi se fait par
jamais avec la prise position que ça va
changer la deuxième chose peut-être que
tout homme fait des affaires que tu
remarques potes puis si c'est le cas et
c'est des remarques et peut-être que non
si puisque c'est la troisième chose
c'est excitant change vraiment ils
connaissaient rien c'est très malheureux
c'est un bon mec parce que là vous avez
un enfant qui arrive puis une relation
tu peux la terminer mais pour toujours
tu vas être liés à cette personne peu
importe dans quelle faculté et on fixe
et un bon temps qu'avec
sur le point injustement team est on
partant avec le présupposé qui changera
peu
puéril avec six essais à la question que
tu aies accepté ce
ça peut dire que mon poids de forme je
faisais des tours et a accepté de
chanter à accepter qu'ils changent peu
il peut s'améliorer un peu moins 500 g
qui
quelques uns des trois mois et demi à 5
je pense que jamais
maintenant y'a personne de parfait et le
goff est peu de ménage mais il est
peut-être tout le temps à la maison
puissant pour mam qui se passe à gauche
peut-être ben jaffar sa liste qui sont
et son talon d'achille c'est le ménage
c'était le meilleur temps du tout un
problème
est retrouvé l'autre que bon lui fait
ménage mais j'en
ressors
toujours
d'accord avec
elle aussi comme tantôt la personne peut
être qu'à ce qu'on parle
six langues il faut que tu sois capable
de mettre le mettre à table de albert b
connaît elle
était jean médecin était folle j'aurai
ce week-end à son affaire la réorganiser
redonner le cpie sont shame c'est comme
un peu le contrat atteint restauration
en plus j'aurais supporté et puis j'en
retire mais y est gentil dit comme
quelqu'un qui jackie chan années ce type
qui éjacule magnétisme de rome et genre
c'est pas lui qui va faire le ménage p
puis à dia est passé en huit ans mais
thomas est en crise parce que j étais
pas son affaire
j'ai accepté le fait que si je vais être
sérieux
c'est moi qui vaut
qu'il va faire l'éloge de nos futurs
enfants six mois qu'il faut faire si
monsieur pigeon ça fait chier mais
je les accepte parce que ses parts à
bien écrire c'est pas mieux puis elle a
décidé que c'était le sacrifice car le
cas face pour tout les bons côtés de
cette relation là puis le fait qu'avec
avec piqué
c'est quand même un peu genre
comme xiam en même temps à égalité
ça peut pas être parfait impossible
quelque chose c'est quand même fort loin
dans le sens qui est ce l'amour et le ça
vaut quand même la peine de d'accepter
une coupure force la
limite
sinon c'est ouais très cool les feuilles
merci devenu merci de nous faire
confiance pour le podcast
on invite les gens qui nous écoutent à
l'écouté les trois premiers épisodes
sont disponibles la suite de la
conversation que vous avez que vous
allez avoir sur le troisième épisode
tout début on souhaite une belle
continuité
je pense que tu es savon et je pense
qu'on sait même pas encore qu'est ce que
ça va
[Musique]
évoluer sa fin le 10 5 x men x temps si
vous avez des questions que vous voulez
que les filles répondent ou des
situations comme on vient de lire le jeu
de votre visite et des fois c'est
intéressant entendre une perspective
externe à votre situation du cru les
prêtres juste des histoires drôles aussi
genre de
saper tout passe aussi du fait que ce
soit sur votre page d'instagram faut
qu'on s'appelle ou faut qu'on s'appelle
au studio sfr
mais c'est le fun ciao